[Music]
on this wednesday night
poisoned the powerful nerve agent used
to try to silence a russian opposition
leader
new evidence of a sinister plot a lethal
dose
is less than a grain of salt the push to
hold the kremlin
accountable sick kids and sick days
new rules during the pandemic sounding
the alarm about canada's at-risk species
what's needed to reverse a troubling
trend
plus a war that changed the world and
canada
we began to step out onto the world
stage the second world war's lasting
legacy
75 years after it ended
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
the mystery about what made a russian
opposition leader critically ill
has been solved german authorities say
they found evidence alexey navalny a
vocal critic of russian president
vladimir putin
was poisoned by the nerve agent novichok
that's the same military-grade nerve
agent used in an attack on
a former russian spy sergei skripal and
his daughter in england two years ago
navalny fell ill during a flight in
siberia last month he was eventually
airlifted to berlin where he remains in
intensive care
his team says he was poisoned on the
orders of president putin
the german chancellor angela merkel says
the world will now look to russia for
answers
but as redmond shannon reports putin is
highly skilled
at avoiding them
an announcement that has again pitted
the west against russia
in a battle
german chancellor angela merkel
unequivocally
identified as the chemical used to
poison russian opposition politician
alexei navalny it's the same
russian-developed substance that the uk
said was used to poison double agent
sergei skripal and his daughter
yulia in england in 2018. they survived
but a british woman exposed to the
chemical died
novichok is one of the more potent
elements of a series that are called a
gunner phosphate nerve agents
a lethal dose just so people can put it
into perspective
is less than a grain of salts worth
in berlin navalny remains in an induced
coma
[Music]
two weeks ago he collapsed in agony on a
plane from siberia to moscow
russian hospital staff and the kremlin
maintain there's
no evidence of poisoning but navalny
supporters
insist he was targeted by president
vladimir putin
in this video believed to be filmed
shortly before the incident
navalny again encouraged russians to
vote tactically
against putin's united russia party in
the wake of the skripal attack western
nations expelled russian diplomats and
imposed new sanctions but there has been
little sign that putin cares about those
or cares that novichok is effectively a
brazen
calling card of the kremlin this is
another message out to navalny
or any other opposition personnel that
are out there to say look
we can get you anywhere at any time
germany and others have hinted at
new sanctions and the eu has demanded a
transparent
investigation by russia that seems
hopeful
at best redmond shannon global news
london
there are reports the u.s department of
homeland security withheld an
intelligence bulletin warning of a
russian plot to spread misinformation
about the mental health of presidential
candidates including joe biden
the democratic presidential candidate
abc news is reporting the bulletin
claims russians were working on plans to
spread allegations american presidential
candidates
have poor mental or physical health in
order to influence the 2020 election
the department of homeland security says
the bulletin failed to meet agency
standards
and was not sent out in this country
political insiders are planning for a
potential federal election this fall
in case you forgot the last one was just
last year
prime minister justin trudeau lost his
majority and now there's a new man
leading the conservative party who wants
to make his mark
you might ask why anyone would even be
thinking about another federal election
so soon especially in the midst of a
pandemic
well our ottawa bureau chief mercedes
stephenson is here to fill us in
mercedes
what's up and how serious are the plans
for a fall federal election
well donna it feels like it was just
yesterday at least here in ottawa that
we just had an election it was one year
and one week ago that it was called
but already the national capital is
buzzing about it happening again
prime minister justin trudeau was on a
virtual tour of british columbia today
and while it's totally normal for a
prime minister to touch base in
different parts of the country
the rhetoric by the liberals recently
has more of a campaign feel
take a listen to what the prime minister
told global bc this afternoon about his
plans for the fall
that's why we're putting together a
throne speech now that will
set up set out this ambitious agenda
before parliament
and parliamentarians can decide because
we're in a minority situation
whether this government has the support
to move forward on this
new agenda that quite frankly nobody ran
an election on a year ago because we
didn't know about covent
so donna right there you have the prime
minister really putting the ball in the
opposition's court saying that they're
going to put it to these parties to
decide
but there is a big political calculus
that everyone has to be thinking about
and it's not just what's in that throne
speech it's do canadians actually
want an election or is there a risk that
they will punish the party
who pulls the plug in the middle of a
pandemic it's something that all the
parties are watching very closely and
they're conducting pools on
but i can tell you that sources in the
liberals conservatives and
ndp say that they are already planning
campaign logistics and will be ready to
go if there is a snap election this fall
for the liberals the advantage of an
election now is a mandate to spend
significant amounts of money on social
programs in that throne speech
and you heard the prime minister making
reference to that there's also a chance
to help to plunge onto the hustings
before the conservative leader has a
chance to really establish his brand and
frankly a chance for the liberals to eat
the ndp's lunch when it comes to policy
the desire to get ahead of a potential
looming recession
could be another factor most political
insiders think that a spring election
is more likely at this point but donna
sometimes speculation like this
generates its own kind of pressure all
right mercedes stevenson in ottawa
thanks erin o'toole played down talk
about an election
this fall the new conservative leader is
still building his team he made some key
appointments today just three weeks
before parliament reconvenes
as our chief political correspondent
david aiken explains
prime minister aaron o'toole is the
first leader of the modern conservative
party
not from western canada he's from
ontario
his chief of staff national campaign
director and other top aides are also
from
eastern canada but o'toole will have a
strong voice from the west in his inner
sanctum
in his newly named deputy leader candice
burgin
someone respected across the country
former cabinet minister someone who's
been a passionate defender
of our conservative party in the past
and will help us mentor and grow our
movement of the future
bergen has represented her southern
manitoba riding since
2008 and both she and o'toole recognize
that western canada's concerns
must be at the heart of conservative
policies one of the things that he's
asked me to focus on
is western alienation and the fact that
westerners need to know that
conservatives know
that this is an issue and that they will
not be ignored o'toole's pick for the
important position of house leader is
gerard deltel of quebec city the
bilingual
deltel is a strong parliamentary
performer respected by all sides
o2 will also continue to signal how
important it will be for his party
to broaden its base i've said repeatedly
we need to reach out and grow our
movement with more women
uh more new canadians and let themselves
see them
see themselves reflected in our
conservative movement but there are
clear differences in the way men
and women are lining up politically
right now a new poll from the angus reid
institute shows that
men prefer the conservatives by a wide
12 point margin
42 percent versus 30 percent for the
liberals
but women prefer the liberals by an
almost as wide
11 point margin 40 percent to 29
for the tories this is a gender gap both
parties will likely have to address
canadians may start to get a sense of
how o'toole plans to do that
when he names his shadow cabinet next
week and then starts to flesh out his
party's platform
donna all right david aiken thank you
there's another health crisis still
going on in canada one that's been
eclipsed by all the attention to covid19
but in parts of this country people are
dying of opioid overdoses
in record numbers opioid-related deaths
have significantly increased during the
covet-19 pandemic
in bc there were a record number of
deaths in may june and july
more than 170 people died from overdoses
in each of those months
canada's health minister patty haidu
tweeted today it's more important than
ever that support is available for
people struggling with addiction
there are widespread calls including
from some premiers and public health
officers
to decriminalize the possession of small
amounts of illicit drugs for personal
use
in his interview with global news today
the prime minister wouldn't commit to
changing the law
but says fewer people are being
prosecuted for personal possession
the public prosecution service of canada
has moved forward with
uh new orders that doesn't involve
prosecuting for small amounts of
personal possession i think this is an
ongoing conversation but
there is no one silver bullet that's
going to
fix this tremendous challenge the prime
minister said any response has to
address
issues like housing and mental health as
well he added his government has moved
forward with opening more safe
consumption sites and taken steps to
increase
a safer supply of illicit drugs
there's a promising new development
tonight about a treatment for people who
are seriously ill with covid19
researchers say they have strong
evidence some cheap widely available
steroids can help in one of several
studies published today in the journal
of american medical association
researchers analyzed data from seven
randomized clinical trials
they found steroids like dexamethasone
which
helps the body battle inflammation
reduce the risk of death of critically
ill covid19 patients by about one-third
the world health organization is now
strongly recommending the steroids be
used
to treat severely ill patients but not
to treat
mild cases a global campaign to provide
every country in the world safe and
equitable access to a vaccine for
covid19 if one is discovered
appears to be faltering the u.s says it
is refusing
to be part of the world health
organization's kovacs initiative
the white house has accused the w.h.o of
being corrupt
and too political there is no nation
that has been or will be as deeply
committed to delivering vaccines all
around the world
but it is also imperative that when we
do that we need to just do so in a way
that's effective
it's not political that it's a science
based
and what we have seen demonstrate from
the world health organization that it
is not that the wh has warned against
vaccine
nationalism and as everyone waits for
the vaccine trials to finish
life is moving on here in canada parents
teachers and schools are embarking on a
big experiment by sending kids back to
school
precautions vary depending on where you
live there are rules about masks and
personal hygiene
and new policies about what happens when
students get sick
as jeff semple reports gone are the days
of going off to school with the sniffles
good job julia silvestri wong is a
mother to three kids
all under the age of seven which
basically means
they're constantly sick my youngest is
going to preschool and they're going to
public school
we're basically sick from october to
march but this year
taking a sick day won't be so simple new
policies to prevent covid19 from
spreading in schools mean minor symptoms
could become major headaches it's scary
because
you don't want to like downplay a
symptom
if your kids got a runny nose but also
what if you have to send them to school
or what what do you do with them
the rules range by province and school
board but most require a student to stay
home if they have even one
of a long list of possible covid19
symptoms
students in british columbia are asked
to consult their doctor and wait till
they're feeling better before returning
to class
in alberta students are legally required
to stay home for 10 days
or until they're feeling better
ontario's rules are even stricter
students must stay home for 14 days
unless they have a negative test
in which case they can return 24 hours
after feeling better
there have been several studies that
have shown that the test is not reliable
this pediatrician worries about relying
on covid19
tests with evidence suggesting they can
sometimes produce
false negatives especially in children
so
any kid with any new symptoms should be
considered to have
as having covid and really should stay
at home but that could quickly add up to
weeks of missed school
younger students in particular typically
catch one viral infection
every month and so it's very conceivable
that especially as we get into
cold and flu season that a child could
have symptoms very typical for covet 19
but have something else
and so that's one of the reason why we
think it's going to be a bit of a
confusing stressful fall health experts
stress the importance of receiving the
flu shot
and practicing proper hygiene to help
ensure children don't catch covid19
or anything else jeff semple global news
toronto going the distance for a good
cause coming up a military veteran steps
into a new mission
against kovid 19.
security was high at a paris courthouse
today for the start of the charlie hebdo
terror trial 14 people are accused of
being accomplices in the attack on the
satirical newspaper's offices
in 2015 and a shooting spree at a kosher
supermarket two days later
three gunmen were killed in police raids
and the attacks left 17 people dead
including several cartoonists at charlie
hebdo the publication was targeted after
it published caricatures of the prophet
muhammad
something considered offensive in islam
the newspaper
republished those images in this week's
edition
pope francis held his first public
audience in six months today and he
declared friday as a day of prayer
and fasting for lebanon
nearly 500 catholics gathered in a
vatican courtyard instead of saint
peter's square
everyone wore masks a lebanese priest
held his country's flag
as the pope called for peace and
dialogue in lebanon
plunging population still ahead a
troubling report on at-risk species
in canada
canada may be a nature lover's paradise
but new research shows
some of our wildlife is in serious
decline natural habitats are
increasingly under threat
that's having a major impact on survival
according to the world wildlife
federation between 1970 and 2016
populations of species assessed as at
risk have fallen an average of 59
percent
and species deemed globally at risk have
plunged by an average of
42 percent in canada robin gill looks at
the decline of these vulnerable species
and what's being done to stop it
in british columbia's interior
volunteers at this bird sanctuary have
been working
diligently to build underground homes
for the burrowing owl
in the 1990s this migratory bird
population
which likes to tunnel dropped by 90
percent
considered endangered there are only
roughly 270 left
the largest issue still eludes this and
that is
having enough owls returning into
our into british columbia such that they
can sustain their population over time
without our interference
a new report from the world wildlife
fund highlights the plight of at-risk
animals
their numbers dwindling in canada i
think it's a growing
urgency knowing that we're seeing these
continued downward trends
there are other animals at risk bare and
ground caribou
also known as reindeer have seen some
herds declined by as much as
98 percent because natural resource
companies are moving in
and destroying their habitats north
atlantic right whales are critically
endangered
only 411 exist in the world largely
because they keep getting killed by
ships or fishing gear
things are not going in the right
direction you know not only are species
declining but
how we are addressing the
nature of the economy that gives rise to
all of these
stressors that we know are problems for
now
projects like the burrowing owl
conservation society have to exist
to monitor their existence the vicious
circle
that humans have to interfere in
protecting a problem
we created robin gill global news
vancouver
next looking back at the second world
war and how it shaped
the present day
99 year old george marco has a lot to
celebrate tonight the second world war
veteran just finished his final lap
of a 100 kilometer mission marco has
been doing laps around his ontario
seniors
residence since april it's his way of
raising money to fight kovid 19.
but he's still a little short of his
goal to raise 100
000 dollars so he plans to keep doing
laps
until he reaches his target he is one of
tens of millions of people who took part
in the second world war
the global conflict lasted six years and
it was the most destructive and
deadliest in history
that war impacted virtually every part
of the world including canada
it formally ended 75 years ago today
though as eric sorenson explains it
sparked changes that remain
to this day from the rise of hitler to
the attack on pearl harbor
it was war that spanned the globe it saw
cities and civilians firebombed
it produced genocide it introduced
nuclear annihilation
more than 70 million people were killed
about 4 percent of the entire world
canada was deeply affected close to 100
000 were killed or wounded
more than a million served in the forces
and countless more
helped the war effort on farms in
factories and in fundraising
canada fought around the world we fought
in the far east we fought in hong kong
we fought in sicily in italy in his book
the fight for history tim
cook says canada's role has not been
adequately chronicled
over the years we forgot about our
contribution
our service and our sacrifice we didn't
do a good job in telling our stories the
formal end of the war the signing of
surrender documents by japan 75 years
ago
set off enormous and enduring change
worldwide for better or worse
the creation of the united nations it
was hoped would bring countries together
to resolve differences
but new boundaries sparked the cold war
and ongoing conflicts
ever since this titanic conflict that
forever changed the world that we live
in that saw the rise of
superpowers saw the cold war saw the
decolonization of many empires
that were still with us today canada
emerged from the war with stronger ties
to the economy and the military of the
united states
but we also forged a canadian path
forward in peacekeeping
and as an influential power in
international trade and diplomacy
and at home emphasis on social inclusion
from pensions for returning veterans
to strengthening public education and
ultimately
universal health insurance the war
stimulated government intervention into
the lives of canadians there was the
baby bonus
uh there was a increased urbanization
there was industrialization we began to
step out onto the world stage that we
saw ourselves as part of the world
community and a force for good
of which we were canada's population
today is triple what it was in 1945.
spurred by immigration a country that
has come of age
striving to be a prosperous and
multicultural model to the world
eric sorensen global news toronto
and that is global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada is buck lake in alberta
southwest of edmonton
we'd love to see your canada please
email it to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching it's good to be back
hope to see you here again tomorrow
take care of yourselves bye-bye